merci la parole et à monsieur axel
poniatowski merci monsieur merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur macron il n'est pas
là je vous la pose donc monsieur le
premier ministre
l'année 2015 restera dans l'histoire de
l'industrie française comme celle où
trois géants de l'industrie
lafarge alstom et alcatel seront passés
sous contrôle étranger
ce coup de tonnerre est révélateur des
faiblesses de notre économie
en cause une politique qui a
considérablement dégradé la
compétitivité de nos entreprises qui
n'ont plus les moyens ni d'investir ni
de reconstituer leurs fonds propres les
dossiers industriels s'accumulent orange
edf air france renault peugeot bouygues
et bien d'autres et voilà maintenant
qu'on apprend la vente par le consortium
franco allemand airbus groupe de tout
son électronique de défense pour plus
d'un milliard d'euros contrairement à la
préconisation du président de l'époque
monsieur louis gallois dans son plan
vision 2020
de plus cette session a été faite non
pas au français thales qui étaient sur
les rangs et qui vient de largement
contribué au succès de dcns
en australie comme le rappelle ministre
de la défense mais elle a été faite à
kkr un fonds d'investissement américain
spécialisé dans l'immobilier les
finances et les chariots élévateurs
on croirait rêver monsieur le ministre
si ce n'était tragique
comment le ministre de l'économie
n'est-il pas intervenu fermement avec
son collègue allemand pour empêcher la
cession d'une telle activité
stratégiques et à forte valeur ajoutée
pour la france veut gourmet retour
la parole la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de la défense je regrette
monsieur le président comme monsieur
poniatowski n'est pas écouter la réponse
que j'ai apportée à cette question il ya
quinze jours dans ce même hémicycle
donc je vais je lui conseille de
retourner à cette réponse qui indiquait
que concernant la partie électronique
d'airbus de la partie défense
électronique
elle était de responsabilité d'activité
et de localisation à dominante allemande
est donc de la responsabilité du
ministre fédéral de l'économie et de la
défense et que la partie française
faisait l'objet d'un examen extrêmement
attentif de la part des autorités
françaises
elle est très minime est fait l'objet
d'un examen très attentif et les
décisions sur ce point ne sont pas
encore prise mais interrogé mois dans 15
jours je vous répondrai à nouveau merci
monsieur le ministre la parole